this is a holiday plan that we put
together and we recommend you drink this
before the holiday meal okay so it's
loaded with superfoods nutrients some
really nice apple juice it could be it's
organic
it could be fresh-squeezed but we're
gonna skip that today we're using some
Rose autumn grapes so these are fresh
from the farmers market they have a
really fragrant flavor almost a little
bit like a flower so we're just gonna
put these in there pull them off their
stem and then rich if you can grab that
mint we're gonna have a lot of herbs
fresh mint from the farmers market so
nice big bunch of basil and what are the
herbs that we love at the holidays
rosemary fresh from the garden this is
white sage it's a sacred sage also from
chai it's got a great smell
okay organic cranberries put some of
those in kale this is dinosaur kale and
then we're gonna go for a couple stalks
of celery and an apple throw the whole
thing in with the peel the core see we
need to put any water in there let's see
okay so we're gonna blend it up this
machine this is a Vitamix this is our
secret weapon so for those of you don't
know a Vitamix is obviously it looks
like a blender but it has like a
turbocharged engine and you can make
juice or soups or all kinds of sauces
out of this thing and it will literally
you know blend anything into a liquid
form so we know it's an expensive item
but we actually couldn't live without it
we love it the traveler will I said it's
key to like everything that we do and if
you're interested in getting a Vitamix
you can go to our website at Jon
lifestyle choice dalkom we have special
rebates appreciate there we go
I think we're ready to fly smell I can
smell it already
it's beautiful okay yeah beautiful